they're random they're weird and
sometimes they're oddly useful
every actor has a special skills section
on their resume
and sometimes the talents listed are
pretty shocking
some of these actors have actually used
their skills for work
and some of them they've just shown off
as a party trick
they're strange funny and unique so
let's see what neat skills these
performers have up their sleeves
i'm not particularly good but i like
doing it
it the spirit of an old literary
character or is it a freaky and oddly
useful talent
whichever it might be the queen's gambit
star
anya taylor joy gave the cast and crew
of the film emma a concerning and
welcome surprise with her perfectly
timed nose blade
awesome had traced on my face where she
wanted it to go
went where awesome's finger went while
it's a super cool and unique talent
we hope she's able to control it if not
maybe she should look for a future in
horror films
let's be honest what can't zendaya do is
there anything she isn't amazing at
now we can add this weird talent to the
list i have an obsession with ice cream
it doesn't hurt we'd probably be
obsessed with ice cream too if we could
eat it like she does
here's hoping she comes out with her own
ice cream line just
imagine how good that would be all hail
zendaya
queen of ice cream patience is a virtue
virtue is a grace
did we just walk into a rap battle nope
that's just cara delevingne being a
beatboxing master
we think she will probably end up being
the backing track on a hit song soon
enough
she seems to be a pretty great teacher
there are two different ways there's
kind of
the outside mouth and the inside mouth
maybe she'll start offering a master
class soon
sign us up he's a wizard on screen
and in the rapping scene who knew this
british star could spit beats so well
not only that but he does it all without
his natural accent
broken barrier is bound in by the bombay
buildings are broken basically i'm
bombarding
he may not think he's that cool but
we're definitely team radcliffe
if he has a rap album coming out you can
guarantee we will be first in line to
buy it
we were pretty shocked to learn that in
her spare time on set
margot robbie was often found wielding a
tattoo gun
here we go i actually haven't done one
for a while
maybe it's not the most conventional
hobby in the world but honestly
it makes us love her even more it's too
bad she's not giving them any more
as we would totally get in line for a
tow moji
is that you marcel marceau nope that
mime is indeed
jennifer lawrence yes she's the one who
talked a lot in the hunger games
but she's also an incredibly talented
silent actor
maybe she'll become a silent movie star
too i feel like nobody wants to hear
we talk i want to hear i want to hear
here
she may have shared it for cara de
levine but we all
benefited how did she learn she had this
hilarious talent
my dad was trying to teach me how to
whistle once when we were driving to
school that's what happened
naturally she looks amazing while she
does it we wonder how many birds she can
do
can she do a toucan a flamingo how about
a penguin
it took us all by surprise when kurt
wielded a sword on glee in season five
as it wasn't like his character at all
turns out
it was more like the actor himself who
knew that he actually
trained himself to use the psy swords
chris apparently
is quite an expert with his correct i'm
kind of a ninja yes
it looks like a martial arts movie is in
his future
how exactly does one find out they have
an insanely talented
tongue we're not sure how this came
about but it certainly is
uh interesting the shake it up star
definitely shakes up the room with this
one in addition to the acrobatic tongue
her sternum also likes to stand out
sometimes
i can like stick my hands under it and i
can pop it in and out kind of like a
heartbeat
maybe this will be useful for a role
we're looking forward to that film
turns out the werewolf has a few more
secrets up his sleeve
look at those skills hard to believe we
can fall even more in love with lautner
even as a kid he was talented lucky he
was already so skilled since it came in
handy when he was doing the film cuckoo
would you do a flip first there's a 50
50 chance that my suit splits we'd
preferred if this is
now this is definitely one of the more
unique talents on our list
can you believe you can understand her
so well even with a closed mouth
just when we thought the ice age
collision course actress couldn't
surprise us
even more with her talent she pulls it
off again
maybe her next album will feature a
closed mouth song
have you ever patted a dog to see if you
could tell what gender it was
anyone apparently breaking bad actor
aaron paul did
or how else would he have discovered
this fascinating skill
by petting it where exactly this on the
back
on the back maybe he can do it with cats
too
we think we smell a new reality show
coming
generally people don't like hearing a
baby cry but when it's ariana grande
we are here for it we knew she was good
at impersonating singers
but this one came as a surprise to us
[Music]
it might not be the most pleasant sound
but she's just so
good at it why does the sam and cat
actor even know she can do this
we wonder where she practices and if the
people who hear her are ever thinking
thank you next we absolutely loved her
version of dancing on my own
and her vocal performance in the
animated film leap but we had no idea
she could actually walk the walk
or dance the dance that is she's so
graceful
we're a bit jealous just another talent
to add to the already extensive list
take your bath zell weger has
actually had quite a few dancing roles
in her days
from roxy heart in chicago to portraying
the legendary judy garland
isn't she just an adorable tap dancer
i'm not gonna get
higher looks like she's definitely way
more coordinated than she was as bridget
jones
time to shuffle off to buffalo renee our
spidey senses are tingling now
my name is andrew and i'm from banstead
and sorry i i
i can do a bit of gymnastics andrew
garfield
is an unbelievably talented gymnast
maybe he wasn't good enough to make the
olympics
but he did rank third in the south of
england on vault and floor routine
definitely not too shabby we loved it
when james mcavoy gave jimmy fallon a
ride
but we definitely didn't expect unicycle
riding anytime
soon is it possible did mark ruffalo and
mcavoy make the one wheel cycle suave
we think that's a yes gina davis has
always been pretty sporty
but we were surprised to learn that she
even did it professionally
i'm gina davis and this is how i arch
that's right the actor was nearly in the
olympics for archery
she only started when she was 40. so
goes to show you
it's never too late mcdreamy
or mcjuggler seems like we can call
patrick dempsey both since discovering
his unique talent
who knew he'd been doing it for so long
of course
he also hosts an incredible event we are
glad he didn't get into the circus when
he auditioned though
because we would definitely miss him on
our screens
i was too young i didn't get accepted
otherwise i would probably would have
run off with a circuit
the mistress america actress is a force
to be reckoned with
but did you know how well she could
handle a fencing sword
her fencing talent goes years back as
she started when she was in school
and even ranked third in all of
california at one point
i think that you'll look super sexy
taking off your mask usually it's just
near sweaty
looks like these performers have all
sorts of talents hidden up their sleeves
and as we've seen you never know when
they'll come in handy and get used on
set
which special skill from this list did
you find most impressive
do you have any similar party tricks up
your sleeves let us know in the comments
section
if you enjoyed learning these facts give
us a like and hit that subscribe button